ah
[Música]
hola bienvenidos al debate de france 24
soy santiago lópez gonzález
la variante omicron sigue con su avance
imparable en el mundo entero el aumento
de los casos de contagio ha subido de
manera estrepitosa afectando
principalmente a europa a eeuu y también
al continente asiático el efecto de la
ola de contagio debido a la variante
omicron ha provocado que las economías
globales registren récords de alza en
los precios al consumidor hay también
escasez de productos se mantiene ese
desorden que hay desde hace ya más o
menos 2 años en la cadena de suministros
y la inflación se siente en
prácticamente todos los países en
diferentes aspectos eso en cuanto a la
economía pero esta ola de contagio de
omicron también ha afectado a la
industria aérea ya que intentaba volver
a retomar el vuelo en plena capacidad
aprovechando la alta temporada de fin de
año que resultó con un caos para los
pasajeros con miles de vuelos cancelados
por falta de tripulaciones por falta de
equipos de vuelo en óptimas condiciones
tras permanecer meses en tierra
incluso la suspensión de los vuelos
desde y hacia eeuu ha generado grandes
problemas para las aerolíneas teniendo
en cuenta que este es un importante
mercado para la explotación en términos
de números de pasajeros y de carga
transportada alrededor del mundo la
industria aeronáutica volvió a verse
seriamente afectada por la pandemia pese
a la reactivación o la pandemia estamos
hablando de este rebote de omicron
también la retoma de algunas rutas y de
las frecuencias que había por allí queda
sobre la mesa qué tan alto ha podido
volar esta industria qué tan alto ha
tenido que
moverse esta industria para poder
sobrevivir con las dificultades que se
le están presentando en el panorama tan
alto como la inflación que se le está
presentando a varios países
principalmente en nuestra región
hablaremos de algunos casos en
particular dos temas que aparentemente
son lejanos pero que están ligados a un
factor común y es la pandemia del cobi
19 y este rebrote de la variante omicron
hoy en el debate de france 24 analizamos
el impacto la inflación a nivel mundial
y también le damos un vistazo a la
industria aeronáutica internacional para
analizar este tema hemos invitado a
maría del pilar lópez uribe ya es
profesora e investigadora de la facultad
de economía de la universidad de los
andes en la ciudad de bogotá en colombia
ella también es doctora en desarrollo
económico de la london school of
economics y se une a esta conversación
desde la ciudad de bogotá la capital
colombiana también está con nosotros
enrique perez la él es editor de airways
magazine una publicación que está
enfocada en la industria aeronáutica
también es piloto comercial ustedes
nuestros televidentes pueden participar
en este debate con sus comentarios y sus
preguntas lo pueden hacer a través de
nuestras redes sociales no se encuentran
en facebook en instagram y en twitter
estamos como france24 bajo ese santi
logo que es mi cuenta personal les
recuerdo la etiqueta es numeral el
debate efe 24 esperamos todos sus
comentarios y sus preguntas en torno a
este tema que nos reúne hoy en el
programa de el debate voy a comenzar
entonces hablando de economía hablando
con maría del pilar en la ciudad de
bogotá sobre el tema de la inflación un
tema
preocupante para las economías a nivel
mundial maría del pilar bienvenida al
programa y con la pandemia del cobi 19
en marcha era previsible que la
inflación a nivel mundial
escalaría de la manera que lo ha hecho
hola santiago
gracias por la invitación pollito para
hablar de este tema de qué tan
previsible era la que la inflación vamos
a aumentar y siguiera el ritmo pareciera
que sí porque a diferencia de las otras
olas inflacionarias y la actual digamos
tiene un factor común que es para todos
los países y además es multicausal no
hay una única razón que la está
explicando en parte un pedazo viene
viene como consecuencia de esas telera
aumento del consumo que se vive en el
2021 luego de que muchas familias
empezarán a gastar mucho menos durante
todos los confinamientos y los momentos
más difíciles de la pandemia que
contribuyeron a aumentar los precios e
hicieron que la demanda se acelerará y
la oferta no pudiera responder al mismo
ritmo esto llevó a ambos unos problemas
logísticos muy importantes este aumento
en la demanda de consumo provocó por
ejemplo escasez en los inventarios y
repentinamente el transporte por ejemplo
el transporte marítimo y marítimo y los
puertos no pudieron manejar y no fueron
capaces de manejar este incremento en la
demanda en el volumen esto generó
congestión en rutas de comercio mundial
algunos puertos estuvieron bloqueados
sin por ejemplo trabajadores suficientes
para cargar y descargar los barcos y eso
también hizo que aumentara el precio el
precio y el precio de los fletes
entonces esto por un lado no llevó a un
aumento importante por estos problemas
logísticos luego hay otros factores
adicionales está por otro lado la
escasez de mano de obra en los países
desarrollados hay otro tema de por
ejemplo falta de insumo para la
fabricación de carros de computadores de
celulares adicionalmente a eso tenemos
un tema de la cantidad de dinero ese
aumento sustancial de dinero que
inyectaron las economías en los momentos
de nuestros pactar estos históricos
paquetes de estímulo fiscal que se
dieran que fueran entregados por los
gobiernos para mitigar todos los
estragos que se pudieron causar durante
la pandemia ustedes al final tenemos que
hay un factor común para todos los
países digamos esto es algo que se
repite consistentemente quizá el tema la
casa de semana obra no pero los demás sí
el aumento en la inflación básicamente
manejada agua conducida por un aumento
en precios de varilla y empresas y
empresas de alimentos y si uno eso les
suma que cada cada país tiene sus
propios problemas países por ejemplo que
están enfrentando devaluaciones de
moneda local muy fuerte claro además de
elecciones temas políticos pues todo
esto va a ayudar eso nos sirve de
contexto para entender por qué estamos
presenciando esta alza en inflación en
algunos países unas alzas históricas
sobre todo ya lo decíamos afectado a
eeuu a los países europeos y pues por
supuesto la región américa latina y el
continente africano también se han visto
afectadas cruzó al otro tema que vamos a
llevar en paralelo aquí en el debate y
converso ahora con enrique para hablar
de aviación para hablar de esta
industria importante también fundamental
para reactivar la conectividad entre las
regiones después de haber estado en un
confinamiento tan largo y prácticamente
aislados en nuestras casas en los
diferentes rincones del planeta
enrique también los saludos bienvenido
al programa como siempre un gusto
tenerlo con nosotros y cuando pensábamos
que por fin ya comenzaban a despegar los
aviones en forma ya reactiva la
industria era llega la variante omicron
y vuelve a dejar a cientos de aviones en
los aeropuertos tripulaciones alejadas
de los aeropuertos por estar contagiadas
y lo peor carga y pasajeros en tierra
sin poder ser transportados
pero así lamentablemente cuando ya
pensábamos que estábamos saliendo de
esta parte crítica de la pandemia llego
omicron y obviamente tiró al piso todos
los planes de la industria tanto de
carga como de pasajeros
es importante mencionar y que la gente
entienda que en la aviación no se
planifica para mañana si no se planifica
para dentro de los próximos 23 años la
decisión que toma un aerolínea hoy no es
para mañana sino para dentro de los
próximos cuatro o cinco trimestres es
decir que si tú planifica comprar un
avión hoy ese avión va a estar operando
para los próximos muchos
por los próximos diez veinte años y por
lo tanto estas capacidades ya vienen
minuciosamente planificadas y por lo
tanto eso viene de la mano con
tripulación viene de la mano con
mantenimiento
- con trabajadores en los aeropuertos y
centenares de otras variables entonces
si omicron llegó en un momento que ya
pensábamos que íbamos de salida
podríamos decir que la única parte
levemente positiva es que omicron llegó
durante una temporada del año que no
necesariamente es la más alta a nivel de
viajes la más alta a nivel de viajes
siempre ha sido el verano y el invierno
siempre se conociera como la parte baja
del año en donde la mayor y la mayor
cantidad de pasajeros permanecen en casa
o simplemente desean no viajar por las
frías temperaturas del hemisferio norte
entonces qué sucede ahora bueno
nuevamente las rutinas se encuentran
destinadas los pasajeros se encuentran
incómodos ante una posible cuarentena al
llegar a países ajenos los tripulantes
se encuentran ante él el miedo constante
de no saber qué van a conseguirse en sus
aviones y por lo tanto estamos
nuevamente ante una crisis sin
precedentes
enriquecido con usted para hacerle una
pregunta rápida antes de pasar otra vez
al tema de la inflación de acuerdo a lo
que usted nos dice entonces el verdadero
impacto de esta ola y de estas
cancelaciones de vuelos sobre todo para
la época de navidad y año nuevo pese a
que como usted lo dice no es la
temporada alta en el hemisferio norte
pero acá en el hemisferio sur es verano
y si lo es
se van a ver reflejados en unos meses
más adelante o sea el el verdadero
impacto no lo vamos a ver en las
próximas semanas sino en un tiempo mucho
más adelante
si eso es correcto recientemente el
presidente de la aerolínea delta que es
la niña más prolífica de los eeuu
declaró que tuvieron un muy positivo
último trimestre del 2021 de hecho
tuvieron las ganancias por primera vez
en mucho tiempo y sin embargo esta
ganancia no se va a replicar en el
primer trimestre de 2022 por el mismo
motivo la gente tiene miedo de viajar en
mi propio caso yo tenía que viajar a
italia
en enero y decidí no voy a estar porque
en italia al ser el país digamos más
radical en cuanto a medidas y
restricciones se refiere
han decidido bloquear el ingreso de
muchas personas que vienen de suramérica
por ejemplo y para poder moverte
libremente para poder subirse en un
avión en un tren entrar a un restaurante
o subirte en un taxi necesitas montar y
demostrar lo que ellos llaman un green
para son pase verde este pase verde no
te lo dan si vienes de suramérica tienes
que hacer unos días días de cuarentena y
por lo tanto en personas como yo han
decidido cancelar sus viajes no sólo
para italia sino para otros países en la
región europea entonces el miedo está
reina entrar o la incomodidad de esta
reinante y obviamente el incertidumbre
de omicron y de otras posibles variantes
van a seguir perjudicando nuestra
industria la incertidumbre que no
solamente afecta a la industria está
afectando el día a día de todas las
labores y sobre todo la economía y la
inflación que estamos presenciando
retoma el tema con maría del pilar en la
ciudad de bogotá y quiero maría alquilar
que hablemos del caso de eeuu usted
mencionaba en aquellos países que han
tenido unos fuertes apoyos a la
industria local y al empresariado dando
bonos y préstamos y dando algunos
métodos para salvar las industrias
durante el proceso de confinamiento y el
cierre de las economías durante el punto
álgido de la pandemia eeuu fue uno de
estos países que tomó este tipo de
acciones cómo está la situación en este
país una inflación
pocas veces vista en este país
norteamericano esto qué secuelas puede
empezar a dejar en la economía cuando se
le está apostando por la infraestructura
por reinsertarse en el comercio
internacional con el gobierno de byd en
cómo lo ve usted
pues bueno
cuando uno mira un poquito como esa
disputa interna sobre sobre la política
sobre la política local en eeuu digamos
no no hay todavía mucho debate sobre si
este alto nivel inflacionario se debe
precisamente como un fracaso de esta
estrategia económica que mencionas o si
se trata de lo que yo estaba mencionando
de disrupciones globales que son
provocadas básicamente por la pandemia
lo que sí es claro es que la inflación
se está acelerando a medida que la
economía se está recuperando que está
aumentando el consumo de la población y
que aún persisten estos cuellos de
botella en las cadenas de suministro que
están afectando el flujo normal de los
productos a nivel global me parece que
esto no se va a recuperar sino
probablemente a finales de este año o
posiblemente el siguiente año entonces
hay unos problemas en las cadenas de
suministro hay una crisis energética que
también están haciendo que suban los
precios de bienes y servicios que sube
sobre los precios de bill y servicios en
plenas temporadas de compra empujado
también por aumento en precios de
alimentos de gasolina vivienda autos
usados ahora eeuu cuenta con otro factor
adicional y es la escasez de
trabajadores una situación que ha hecho
subir salarios en algunos sectores de la
economía y este problema en el mercado
laboral es otro de los grandes desafíos
que enfrenta la economía estadounidense
los estadounidenses están renunciando a
los trabajos a un ritmo récord y no es
muy claro digamos qué es lo que va a
pasar no y esto es el abandono digamos
de estos de estos empleos están dando a
distintos niveles y es mucho más
evidente por ejemplo en sectores donde
hay trabajadores con remuneraciones más
bajas y en sectores donde hay personas
que están más expuestas por ejemplo a
contagiarse y este récord de las
personas que están renunciando puede
tener un efecto vamos pues indicar que
los salarios han aumentado por ejemplo
una tasa anual superior a lo que estaba
contando y bueno y esto puede claramente
contribuir contribuir a la inflación
ahora adicionalmente este tema está toda
la discusión en sobre las tasas sobre
las tasas de interés en eeuu las tasas
de interés ha mantenido en los últimos
años en un nivel cercano a cero y la fed
ya ha anunciado que es muy probable que
este año haya algunos aumentos
y hay una discusión también y la
discusión este año va a girar también en
torno a qué tan rápido lo va a hacer y
en qué tamaño lo hace y esto es muy
importante que mencionada porque en
cualquier decisión que tome la fed no
solamente afecta a eeuu si puede tener
reacciones inmediatos en los mercados
financieros y tener un efecto cadena que
va a generar consecuencias en el resto
de las economías alrededor del mundo
especialmente economías emergentes por
ejemplo como
latinoamericanas precisamente para allá
me dirigía maría del pilar esto en
cuanto a eeuu que es un país con una
economía inmensa una economía gigantesca
pero que hay de la región de américa
latina que podemos partirlo en 22 puntos
para esta conversación hay economías muy
dispares economías muy grandes otras muy
pequeñas poco tecnificadas es una región
muy muy desigual en este en este ámbito
cuál es el panorama general que usted ve
de la región en torno a este aumento de
la inflación no mencionemos todavía
casos muy puntuales para luego
analizarlos como algunos casos críticos
en la región
américa latina fue una de las regiones
más afectadas por la pandemia y también
cerró el año como la región con un mayor
aumento de los precios en los precios de
el mundo y la inflación digamos que de
américa latina que la versión vivió en
el 2021 como ninguna otra región llegó a
sus economías más grandes por ejemplo
como brasil y méxico tuvieran el alza
sus alzas más altas en años de precios y
obviamente esto ha agudizado problemas
unos problemas en otras en otras
regiones importantes que siempre han
tenido como estos como este fantasma de
inflación como es el caso como es el
caso de argentina
nuevamente la situación es muy parecida
a lo que ya he mencionado un contexto
global donde hay bastante liquidez donde
hay estos problemas en las cadenas de
suministro donde estamos enfrentando un
aumento en el precio de las materias
primas especialmente como por ejemplo
estaba mencionando el tema de alimentos
y la energía- adicionalmente a esto en
la depreciación de las monedas
latinoamericanas es bastante fuerte y va
acompañado de una fuerte recuperación
del consumo entonces en el caso
latinoamericano comida gasolina
energía están son los que están
empujando a las subidas las subidas
inflación access cuál es el problema
pues que estos son productos de primera
necesidad y son las familias más
vulnerables las que van a sufrir los
efectos más duros en el costo de vida
ahora las mayores economías de la región
están tratando de controlar de controlar
este aumento en el precio a través del
mecanismo más tradicional que es el
acento es el aumento de las de las tasas
de las tasas de interés y esto va a
hacer que el aumento en las tasas de
interés para aumentar el costo del
dinero que esto va a tener un efecto
importante en la desaceleración
económica general y bueno sabemos que
unas tasas más altas implican por
ejemplo costos de financiamiento más
elevados
para economías emergentes en el caso de
que eeuu por ejemplo se hubiera sus
tasas en particular como es en mi caso
de américa latina que las que suelen de
euro en dólares
muchos de estos países por ejemplo en en
la región ya están rezagados en relación
a la recuperación una recuperación
económica global que se está dando claro
y por tanto cuando se vayan a subir
estas tasas en
eeuu que implican costos de
financiamiento más altos
pues van a tener una menor capacidad
para absorber los gastos adicionales que
si bien varía enfilar dejamos sobre la
mesa retomó la conexión con enrique pero
dejamos sobre la mesa para que estemos
conectados el caso de venezuela el caso
argentina y pensemos en otro caso que
usted quiera destacar para la siguiente
pregunta para que analicemos esos esos
tres casos puntualmente retomó la
conexión con enrique para seguir
hablando de la industria aeronáutica que
le ha dejado cerca de doscientos dos mil
millones es lo que le ha dejado lo que
le ha costado la pandemia de kobe 19 a
la industria aeronáutica desde que
comenzó la crisis sanitaria a nivel
internacional y en qué aspectos ha
afectado más allá de la parte económica
y las pérdidas que otros aspectos se han
visto seriamente afectados en esta
industria que ha cambiado en la
industria aérea en estos dos últimos
años de pandemia enrique
santiago es importante recordar que la
aviación existe gracias a las personas
el slavia hasta un 9 el mundo mueve las
economías y sin las personas disponibles
para viajar y si las personas
disponibles para volar los aviones
hacerles servicio etcétera etcétera es
muy difícil que las economías se
recuperen a nivel mundial entonces qué
significa el alto de tantos aviones
alrededor del mundo en tantos
aeropuertos pues significa pérdida de
trabajo significa que las aerolíneas van
a tener la liquidez para seguir
creciendo al final cuando un aerolínea
crece hay más oportunidades de trabajo
tanto para pilotos tripulantes e
inclusive personas
de bajo nivel de preparación entonces al
final todo eso se traduce en que el
mundo se va a mover con menos facilidad
el precio de los boletos va a seguir
subiendo porque mientras menos vuelos
hayan más altos serán los precios de los
boletos y por lo tanto va a haber menos
oportunidad para más personas de volar
entonces es una crisis que va a seguir
presente por los próximos años ya que
las aerolíneas venían con un alza un
crecimiento impresionante en los últimos
10 años y de un día para otro en marzo
del 2020 todo esto se vino abajo los
aviones tuvieron que dejar de ser
producidos dejaron de fabricarse dejaron
de entregarse y por lo tanto todas las
predicciones que habían hecho en los
años 2012 2013 en adelante pues han
tenido un alto bastante brusco entonces
como te mencioné las expectativas que el
primer trimestre del año que viene va a
ser fuertemente afectada por micrón y
quien sabe otra variante sin embargo ya
con las vacunas más al alcance de todos
los pasajeros y tripulantes pues
esperemos que los gobiernos encuentren
una manera más equitativa de cómo tratar
a los pasajeros internacionales que
entren en sus países porque en este
momento ese es el problema más grande
que no hay una no hay una cooperación
igualitaria entre todos los países y por
lo tanto unos toman unas decisiones que
afectan a otros y las aerolíneas están
en el medio esperando esperando las
decisiones que sean todas iguales las
restricciones que ponen los gobiernos
con el ánimo de mitigar el impacto de la
y también yo le sumaría el alto precio
del petróleo ya está en máximos
similares a los del 2018
eso no facilita el panorama de
recuperación enrique cómo está la
aviación a nivel de américa latina esa
retoma de rutas la retoma de frecuencias
de volumen de pasajeros de transporte de
carga que es muy importante sobre todo
en américa latina que es una región tan
grande en muchos casos es mucho más
fácil transportar vía aérea que por
barcos y bueno pues también vemos los
problemas que hay en la cadena de
suministro a través de los puertos
entonces el avión se vuelve la mejor
alternativa
claro históricamente la aviación
latinoamericana depende mucho de la
norteamericana por qué porque los vuelos
del sur al norte mayor dado que son
vuelos tan largos de seis horas a nueve
horas de duración ellos cuentan mucho
con la carga y tal como lo mencionó la
doctora y la carga se ha visto mermada
en estos tiempos porque no hay
suficiente personal para poder manejar
esa carga subirla en los aviones
descargarla en los eeuu han habido
retrasos importantes en las aduanas
tanto en latinoamérica como en el norte
y a su vez la falta de tráfico del norte
hacia el sur ha causado que en el sur en
suramérica se se vea una
disminución importante en el tráfico de
pasajeros ahora brasil ha mantenido su
tráfico relativamente estable en los
últimos los últimos seis meses los
últimos seis meses han sido algo
positivos alrededor del mundo ya que
como lo mencioné anteriormente la
vacunación ha sido un poco más asequible
para todo el mundo sin embargo sigue esa
incertidumbre y las aerolíneas no están
apostando lo todo a aumentar el tráfico
en este momento muchos aviones a
servicio al porque están a la
expectativa de que pueda suceder a nivel
sanitario tanto en el sur como en el
norte si maría del pilar retoma la
comunicación con usted teníamos
pendiente analizar el caso de venezuela
argentina los pongo sobre la mesa porque
llama la atención que venezuela salió de
la hiperinflación que ha venido
presentando los últimos años tiene una
dolarización prácticamente de facto en
muchos aspectos de su economía y
argentina venía enormemente endeudada
antes de empezar esta crisis sanitaria y
con muchos problemas económicos estos
países como están enfrentando esta
crisis de inflación que enfrenta al
mundo entero por la pandemia pues bueno
en el caso venezuela vamos a diferencia
como el resto de países de la región él
lo que uno parece ver por lo menos en
estos en estos en términos
inflacionarios es un es un patrón un
poquito distintos campos venezuela venía
con una hiperinflación desde más o menos
noviembre del 2017 y parece que
finalmente está saliendo porque llevaban
12 meses con un aumento de los precios
que es inferior al 50 por ciento al 50
por ciento mensual entonces esto nos
podría hacer pensar que podría estar
saliendo como periodo periodo negro
normalmente la medida económica estrella
a venezuela en esto 2021 fue la entrada
a la entrada en vigor el 1º de octubre
de esta nueva moneda que es el bolívar
digital que eliminó 6 ceros con respecto
al anterior al bolívar soberano lo que
va a representar lo que representa es
una tercera reconversión en lo que va
del siglo pero parece que digamos puede
estar impulsando este impulsando este
este patrón positivo de salir de este
extremo de esta década de estas décadas
negras inflacionarios de venezuela en el
caso de argentina en este aumento de la
inflación sigue es uno de los
principales problemas macroeconómicos
que siguen siguen siguen como un
fantasma la argentina en los últimos dos
décadas excepto un par de años de como
todos los índices de inflación anual han
sido mayores y sin mayores y no han sido
de los dígitos en el caso en particular
del 2021 cerró con una inflación
de más del 50 por ciento muy por encima
por ejemplo del 2020 y lo que se lo que
se pensaba que iba a ser la del 2021 por
el banco por él concentrada ahora esto
se debe a que una política expansiva que
se aplicó para lo que estamos
mencionando para atender todos los
efectos y las consecuencias de la
pandemia y estimular la economía tras
una fuerte percepción que ya venía desde
el 2018 al 2000 a 2020 y con un banco
central que básicamente ha recurrido
completamente la emisión monetaria para
para financiar al gobierno
adicionalmente adoptada por otro tipo de
políticas de precios regulados congelar
precios de productos de consumo masivo
por ejemplo alimentos
medicamentos y abbas ha limitado las
exportaciones de carne de carne vacuna
ha subsidiado fuertemente la energía
pero parece que estas políticas no no no
han sido muy exitosas maría del pilar y
rápidamente en este panorama américa
latina que países lo están logrando
manejar relativamente bien a pesar de
las dificultades que implica esta
inflación alta
pues yo diría yo diría que colombia un
mal que bien está está
manejando relativamente bien en términos
de crecimiento y en términos de
inflación nosotros estamos por encima de
lo que fue nuestra inflación objetivo en
2021 pero igual fuimos una de las una de
las inflaciones más bajas más bajas de
la presión sin embargo lo que el
panorama el 2022 estaba muy incierto
porque tenemos elecciones presidenciales
en el camino el aero muy donde hay
certidumbre inmensa entonces a pesar de
que en el 2021 no lo hicimos tan mal
relativo a otros países de la región no
se puede vamos estuvo estuvo a mente
peor a lo que pudimos fuimos haber hecho
sin pandemia pero tenemos un 2022 al que
igual que brasil vamos a tener
elecciones presidenciales y esto puede
cambiar completa completamente el
panorama económico del país
enrique en los últimos días hemos visto
una disputa entre las aerolíneas y las
aerolíneas de eeuu y las autoridades de
este país en torno a la puesta en marcha
de la tecnología 5g en este país las
aerolíneas
han dicho que cancelarían algunos vuelos
en algunos aeropuertos que quedan muy
cerca los centros urbanos de las
ciudades estadounidenses incluso algunas
aerolíneas
internacionales también han suspendido
algunos vuelos a eeuu
es tan riesgoso esto para la aviación la
puesta en marcha del 5g y esto que tanto
va a afectar a estas crisis que vienen
arrastrando las aerolíneas por la
pandemia
si santiago así afecta y afecta en
manera importantísima
permiten explicarte brevemente los
aviones en las cabinas de vuelo hay un
instrumento que se llama radioaltímetro
el radioaltímetro te dice la altura que
tiene la visión sobre el suelo sobre el
nivel del suelo que tienes abajo ese
instrumento es fundamental para poder
aterrizar en situaciones de visibilidad
reducida y también te puedo decir en
situaciones de visibilidad cero hoy día
los aviones pueden aterrizar sin ver
para afuera es una cosa maravillosa que
gracias a este a este instrumento que
será radioaltímetro pueden hacer ahora
la banda 5g la banda 5g que es una banda
nueva que va a ofrecer una velocidad
increíble de navegación a través de los
celulares es una banda que tiene una
frecuencia que hace interferencia con
estos radioaltímetro por lo tanto
aviones ciertos aviones en este caso
serían los boeing 787 774 7-8
tienen una interferencia importante con
la banda 5g y se han visto ya un par de
casos casualmente en el aeropuerto de
palm beach en florida un avión que venía
perfectamente aproximando la pista
le sonaron alarmas de que iba a
colisionar con el suelo cuando no era en
realidad es el caso después de hacer una
investigación aerolínea descubrió que
por culpa de la interferencia que tuvo
la banda 5g con los instrumentos del
avión estas alarmas sonaron y por lo
tanto en una situación crítica como lo
es de cero visibilidad esto sería una
potencial catástrofe entonces que
decidieron las aerolíneas
internacionales como emirates como el
inegi
como british airways inclusive que
tienes los aviones decidieron cancelar
los vuelos
hasta que éste tomara una decisión y en
conjunto con las
las telefonías con el diente y verizon
en este caso en los eeuu para llegar a
un acuerdo ahora lo lamentable es que ya
han pasado un par de años de que se
anunció la posible instalación de esta
banda y la efe a apenas dos días antes
de su activación fue que se soltaron
este esta directiva en la que
recomendaban no volar esos aviones a
territorio norte norteamericano enrique
rápidamente porque ya estoy llegando a
la recta final del programa esto
entonces se traduce otra vez en pérdidas
para las aerolíneas tener que dejar
aviones en sus bases suspender rutas
lucrativas hacia los eeuu
números negativos
mira fíjate que el 45 por ciento de la
flota de los estados unidos actualmente
tiene el sistema que hace interferencia
con la banda 5g entonces no hace falta
explicar mucho cuando el 45% de una
flota de más de 5000 aviones se ve
afectada entonces si es realmente casi
un nocaut en una época que se esperaba
salir adelante y no sé no se está
logrando y puede ser la estocada final
para muchas aerolíneas que no tienen
músculo económico y pues les afectará
considerablemente retomo para el cierre
del programa el tema de la inflación
marc y al final me quedan pocos minutos
en cómo se puede revertir esta situación
en palabras muy claves y muy puntuales
para las personas que no somos
economistas desde su punto de vista cómo
puede empezar a mejorar esto
entonces es un poquito es un poco
difícil precisamente porque es un
fenómeno global las típicas soluciones
que uno podría pensar para manejar
dentro de las dentro de cada país pues
dependen en gran medida lo que pasa en
el resto del mundo y sobre todo cómo
avanza por ejemplo el proceso vacunación
y el potencial de aparición de nuevas
variantes del cob y sin embargo muchos
de estos países están intentando
utilizar esta herramienta clave para
manejar la inflación que es el aumento
en las tasas de interés al subir las
tasas de interés el costo de pedir
prestado
aumenta obtener esto claramente va
afectar las empresas y los consumidores
que llevan a que requieren créditos para
hacer inversiones para comprar una casa
para solamente consumo entonces el
problema es que cuando las economías
recién están tratando de levantar la
cabeza después de estas de esta recesión
pues esto es un show que las tasas de
interés más altas no van a ayudar a
apuntalar la la la recuperación de todas
formas la subida en las tasas es la
forma más directa de controlar las
presiones inflacionarias estos países
están recurriendo esta medida incluidos
los sonidos que parece que lo va a ser
largo el 2022 y para los de lo que de
américa latina donde los bancos
centrales ya han empezado a subir las
tasas de interés a toda velocidad para
frenar y para detener para detener los
precios sí y también para el cierre la
conclusión desde el sector aeronáutico
enrique qué esperan ustedes para el 2022
no barrones turbulencias como ven
ustedes este este año para este sector
muy difícil para decirlo santiago hasta
que los gobiernos no se pongan de
acuerdo y los reguladores no se pongan
de acuerdo yo creo que es realmente
difícil
ser muy optimista yo sí creo que el
nivel de vacunación ha sido muy muy
efectivo y sí creo que las aerolíneas ya
han tomado lo suficiente las suficientes
medidas para tratar de no aglomerar
tantas personas dentro de los aviones y
hacerlos sentir incómodos pero
nuevamente todo depende de la política
todo depende de las decisiones
sanitarias que tome cada país para que
esta industria es tan importante y tan
vital para el mundo entero pueda salir
adelante pues ya veremos cómo se va
desarrollando este 2022 en términos
económicos y cómo afecta esto a la
industria aeronáutica enrique perez la
en la ciudad de caracas y a maría del
pilar lópez uribe en la ciudad de bogotá
en colombia les agradezco por haber
estado con nosotros y haber puesto en
palabras simples estos dos temas
complejos de economía y de industria
aeronáutica que han sido afectadas por
esta ola de contagio de la variante
omicron a nivel mundial ustedes muchas
gracias por la sintonía y pueden seguir
dejando todos los comentarios y sus
preguntas a través de las redes sociales
y por supuesto pueden seguir viendo
france24 siga con nosotros
[Música]